COREY: What can I help you with?
Well, I found this, and I'm
hoping it's worth some money.
That's pretty cool.
This is from the Civil War.
It is interesting.
I mean, at one point, there
was people in the Senate
and Congress and
stuff that wanted
50% of all males
living in the South
to write a written
apology for the war.
Really?
Could you imagine what
the world would have
been like if they did that.
[laughing]
I have a Southern Orphan
Association Certificate.
I found it in my
parents' attic in a box
of all old papers and photos.
I think it was, like, from
my great-grandparents.
I'm hoping the certificate
is worth, like, maybe $500.
What are you
looking to do with it?
- Well, sell it.
- Sell it?
OK.
Any idea what you're
wanting to get out of it?
I'm hoping, like, around $500.
Um-- it very well could be
worth $500, I have no idea.
I don't even know
if it's real, so.
SHIRLEY: Right.
I understand.
When it comes to Southern
money, Southern stuff
like this, it's forged a lot.
Oh, really?
I've got a buddy who is
really, really good with paper
money stuff like this.
Do you mind if I have him come
down and take a look at it?
No, that would be great.
All right, I'll be right back.
Feel free to take a
look around the store,
and I'll grab you
when he gets here.
OK.
Thanks.
They said they were going
to call in an expert.
I'm thinking it
might be counterfeit,
so I'm kind of nervous.
It's pretty cool, but a lot of
Confederate stuff can be fake.
So I called up Peter to
come down and check it out.
So Southern Orphan
Association Certificate.
Well, this is pretty cool.
This is General
Stonewall Jackson,
and he's featured on here.
And this is post-Civil War.
This was during the
Reconstruction period.
I didn't notice that
was Stonewall Jackson.
- That is.
- That dude was gnarly.
Yeah, he was an intense man.
He was, essentially, General
Lee's right-hand man.
He passed away from pneumonia.
And many believe that
if he didn't pass,
that the war would have
drastically changed.
Yeah.
General Lee, for all intents
and purposes, was a good guy.
Now, to have the
main guy like that,
that guy has got to have the
guy that does the dirty work.
And the guy that did the dirty
work was Stonewall Jackson.
This guy would go into
a town in West Virginia
and he would burn
the whole thing down.
Kind of ironic that he would
be on this, since he's the one
who burned everything down.
Well, he burned stuff down
in the North, not the South.
Yeah, in the South
he was the man.
This is a pretty significant
time in our history, where
the country,
specifically the South,
came together, rebounded,
and created opportunity
for the children and
the widows of lives
lost during the Civil War.
I'm assuming it
was like welfare
or food stamps for Southern
orphans and widows.
Well, kind of, sort of.
During the Civil War, about
a quarter million soldiers
lost their lives in the South.
So this particular
association was actually
designed to fund orphans
who didn't have food
or needed to survive somehow.
This isn't a
payable certificate.
This, in my opinion, is believed
to be a donation receipt.
So it is not currency.
PETER: It is not currency.
OK.
I assumed it was currency.
I assumed it was issued by
the United States government.
But essentially, it's a receipt
saying that you donated $1.
Correct.
There's not a lot of information
on this, surprisingly.
But that's the consensus of
the experts in the field.
OK, so obviously
this isn't fake.
It is genuine.
There's really no reason
to replicate this.
COREY: So what do you
think it might be worth?
This is exceptional
in quality.
It's the nicest I've seen.
They're not rare,
but they're cool.
They have a lot of history.
I would put a retail
number of $175.
OK.
I appreciate it, my man.
- Anytime, buddy.
I'll see you soon.
Good luck.
Thank you.
While the certificate
isn't rare, it is cool.
It would be a
definitely good buy,
'cause it would cater to pretty
much anyone that is a Civil War
relic collector, or just
the general public which
find United States
history fascinating.
It's not worth what I
had hoped it would be.
Yeah, and it's not as cool
as I hoped it would be either.
I'd give you about
75 bucks for it.
Really?
COREY: Yeah.
How about $125?
You'd make $50.
I'll give you 100 bucks.
OK.
Done.
It's a deal?
SHIRLEY: Deal.
All right.
Meet me right over there.
- OK.
Thank you.
Knowing what the retail price
was, I think the $100 was fair.
This certificate was
to help children,
and I'm going to
use the $100 I made
to help my own grandchildren.